Now in a previous lesson, we looked at how AS path pre pending, can be used
to control inbound traffic. As it turns out,
longest prefix match, can also be used to
control inbound traffic. Suppose, that ASA owns 10.1.0.0/16,
and it might advertise that prefix Both of
it's upstream links and that route might similarly
be advertised further upstream. Now of course as
we know from a previous lesson, given the
advertisement of one prefix upstream, ASD is going to
pick one best BGP route; along which to
send traffic back to A. But let's suppose
that ASA wanted to balance that traffic, across
its incoming links. Well in that case, ASA
could actually advertise routes for 2 more specific
prefixes, effectively splitting the slash 16 in half,
so in addition to advertising 10.1/16, across
both links, ASA might advertise 10.1/17 on
the top link and 10.1.128.0/17, the other half of the /16 on the bottom
link. Now, if either link fails, the covering /16 will ensure that the prefix
remains reachable by one of the two
upstream links. But because longest prefix match.
Wins the traffic for 10.1.128 would now traverse
the bottom link, and the traffic for 10.1/17 would
now traverse the top link, effectively sending traffic
for half of the prefixes along the top path
and traffic for the other half of the
prefixes along the bottom path. Although we just explored
a perfectly good reason to deaggregate a contiguous prefix,
it turns out that sometimes autonomous systems may deaggregate
larger prefixes unnecessarily. A report called
the CIDR Report, which is released weekly,
shows autonomous systems who are advertising IP
prefixes. That, at least according to observation,
are continuous and could be aggregated. For example, the top offender for the
week of December 12th, 2013, was AS6389.
This single autonomous system, is actually advertising
more than 3,000 unique IP prefixes. The cider report analysis, suggests that.
With appropriate aggregation, this autonomous system
could instead advertise only 56, unique, IP
prefixes. Now this might be overly optimistic. As we just explored, there
are perfectly good reasons, to deaggregate
a contiguous IP prefix, into multiple smaller
contiguous IP prefixes. But nonetheless, the report shows,
that there are probably a lot more IP prefixes,
in the Global Internet Routing table, than there
could be, if AS's took full advantage of aggregation.